the united states has killed the leader
of al-qaeda in a drone strike in the
afghan capital kabul president joe biden
said intelligence officials tracked
ayman azawahiri to a home in the center
of the city
al jazeera's ali
joins us now from kabul so ali first of
all what more details are emerging about
this attack
so
what's really important to keep in mind
is if you look behind us we're in a
central part of the city you know we're
near bank we're near a grocery store
we're near money exchanges all sorts of
like basic civilian things and this
house that zawahiri was allegedly
staying in reportedly belonged to
someone tied to the government if not a
government official himself a guest
house belonging to the government so
this may be part of why anthony blinken
is saying that you know that this
violated uh the doha agreement because
it's very high difficult to hide you
know the most senior al qaeda leader in
the middle of your capital without
someone from your government knowing and
earlier we tried to go near the site
itself actually still several hundred
meters away but we were told by the
taliban that we're not allowed to shoot
in that site in that area you know they
were saying what what are you shooting
why are you here we said it's the news
you know the event that just happened
you know they responded there's no event
nothing happened why are you here
and we had to go a little bit further
and you know on these streets earlier in
the day there was much more of a taliban
presence
other journalists who i tried to get
near the site also had similar issues so
there definitely is something going on
ali as you mentioned there it's actually
both sides the us and the taliban are
accusing each other of violating the
doha accord what practical impact can
this have though on the the doha
understanding
it's you know again it's one of these
things where you know the the us is
blaming it because that zawahiri was
allegedly here and the taliban because
of the drone strike itself with and the
taliban never really has yet to
acknowledge that zawahiri was the one
killed in this strike they just said
that a strike took place and that it's
in violation of it and really again it's
just another complicating matter in the
in this odd relationship between the
taliban and the rest of the world you
know you see world leaders we saw them
in tashkant in uzbekistan only about a
week or so ago sitting down with the
taliban negotiating potentially
the u.s saying that there may be some
indications that they would eventually
release the central bank reserves that
are with them and then this happens and
both sides are blaming the other
um
so so it's really you know another
instance of this odd relationship
between the islamic emirate and the rest
of the world who on the one hand meets
with them on the other hand doesn't
recognize them and then also stages
these attacks uh accusing the islamic
emirate of housing international
terrorists
right and life behind you seems to be
quite vibrant what kind of impact is
this having so far we know especially it
comes at a time when there are
negotiations underway to free up aidan
assets for afghanistan
i mean right now people are just sort of
confused obviously life goes on you know
this attack took place at least a day
ago if not two days ago depending upon
whose account you uh believe
uh but really right now for the average
person it's just a question of as i said
before a strange circumstance you know
what is going on how is it that this
drone strike took place and initially
the government reported it as a rocket
attack on an empty house and then today
it's being condemned by
uh the islamic emirate as a violation of
the doha accord you know as an as a
drone strike as an attack on their
sovereignty what they see is their
sovereign territory and at the same time
you know
at least a day if not two days later joe
biden is coming out and saying by the
way in that strike uh i'm in uh al
zawahiri was being housed uh
in this in in this residence so it it to
the average person it's all very strange
it's all very odd and not none of it
really seems to add up
all right thanks so much a little thief
there